strive dark and early good morning Nate
Good morning Sherry and good morning to
you Jana early on a Friday morning it is
pretty quiet out there no crashes to
report a couple of them just cleared so
we're going to head on down to what's
going to be your next big traffic
nightmare we've been talking about the
Tropicana I-15 project with some Lane
restrictions off and on the freeway the
focus has now changed to Tropicana where
the westbound lanes over the freeway are
going to be torn down in fact John and
Heather the the folks at the Nevada
Department of Transportation have a name
for this now oh really what is it look
at your screen
here's a live look right now there's
nothing going on this is going to be
happening in the first couple of weeks
of January the westbound Lanes from the
strip over towards the 15 are going to
be torn down right now you have all
lanes available so that is the good news
but lots to think about and lots to
prepare for over the next few weeks John